you were watching television TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
the Internet it was originally born out
of sheer panic of the United States
after the launch of Sputnik 1 from the
Soviets its aim was to further the
chances of America surviving a
catastrophic Soviet nuclear attack and
also satisfy the need for faster
knowledge transfer but today the
internet stands for something very
different it has now become much larger
more influential and integral than any
technology developed before the Internet
has been around since the 1970s but the
public only gained access in 1991 but as
with everything there's been a few key
moments that would lead to what it is
today but what are those key moments and
what are the stories behind the
individuals and moments that would
become the first steps in an incredible
time for human history in this episode
you hopefully learn something new and
have a little bit of fun along the way
we'll go through the history of the
internet looking at key moments that
would change the world although somewhat
disputed the general consensus is that
the first email was sent by ray
Tomlinson to himself in 1971 he is a
quote from him in an interview
I was actually working on a mail program
but it was programmed for a single
computer so that you could send messages
from yourself to another user on the
same time sharing computer and I had
written a couple of programs to transfer
files and it occurred to me that since
the mailbox that I was sending these
messages to was nothing more than a file
I could send that file across the
network instead of keeping it within the
same machine and so I put two programs
together modified the code a little bit
then the first email program was was
created ironically what would become one
of the most popular applications on the
Internet was a program Tomlinson wrote
on his own time it just seemed like an
interesting thing to do with a computer
in the network and so I just did it the
funny thing is that he wrote the program
for email in his own time and nobody at
his company really cared about it it was
also rather pioneered these of the
outside for the email
[Music]
the first website came online in late
1990 at the time Tim berners-lee was
working at CERN laboratories he wanted
to make the internet easier to use at
the time he literally had to be an
expert computer commands just to work
the Internet he wanted to link
information together and let users
browser twirl by themselves what he had
in mind was the World Wide Web
well there was 1989 and the Internet
already existed and that you could send
email but there was no websites I sold
those no HDPE was not Gmail there was no
space or things you could click through
and it began because I was frustrated it
didn't exist and my imagined a system
where you could just click from one to
the other and that was so compelling
that I decided that I wanted to build it
and on the 20th of December 1990 the
first web page was put up and you're
looking at it right now for the first
time the internet was within reach of
the average person everybody could use
it now the first web page was simply a
little bit of a guide as to what the
world wide web was and how to use it the
original page no longer exists but a
later copy from 1992 can be found at
this web address here's a fun fact as it
turns out the world wide web was built
on a next computer and it was actually
Steve Jobs he founded the company next
during his time away from Apple after
being fired in 1985 his Steve Jobs
hadn't been fired we may not have the
web as we know it's pretty interesting
how things link together
[Music]
so what was the first picture uploaded
on the web again
it was Tim berners-lee and this time for
a bit of fun in 1990 some of Tim's
fellow employees at CERN formed a parody
band one day in 1992 Tim asked to scan
some of the photos and said that he
wanted to publish them on some
information system called the World Wide
Web that he'd just invented they didn't
really think much of it and they handed
over the photos little did they know
that this was going to be a historic
moment the very first picture in the
internet what about the first search
engine
although internet search engines had
been around for a while even before the
World Wide Web
they were very limited in nature and
only contained a few pages the first
full text web browser search engine like
the ones we have today is something that
you've probably never heard about it was
called web crawler and was launched back
in 1994
it wasn't until 3 and a half years later
when Google arrived on the scene that
web crawler basically faded into
obscurity
[Music]
[Applause]
in 1994 five years before the 10-block
was even coined justin hall was doing
just that
justin's web-based diary was called
justin's links from the underground it
offered an early guide to the web but
drifted into personal territory over
time the New York Times Magazine
referred to him as one of the founding
fathers a personal blog wasn't until
1997 that the term web blog was coined
this later got shortened to the word
blog
the first mobile phone with Internet the
first phone with Internet connectivity
was the Nokia and 9000 communicator it
launched in Finland back in 1996 but
unfortunately the actual cost of
accessing the Internet was so high that
it was pretty much unsustainable
it wasn't until 1999 that I mode was
launched in Japan and this was
considered the birth of the mobile
internet of course the marriage between
the mobile phone and the Internet has
gotten so large that has completely
changed Society the world's first
internet celebrity the first internet
celebrity was mahira Calgary from Turkey
anyone under the age of 25 is probably
scratching their heads on who this guy
is but he was the original internet
celebrity in 1999 his web site kisi org
established him as the first person to
achieve celebrity status solely through
the internet his web site was full of
broken English and happy snaps but by
2000 Bill Gates was even said to be one
of his fans
mahira ended up in the Guinness Book of
Records for the most page visits to a
personal home page estimated at 12
million at the time some say that he was
the original inspiration for the Borat
movie in 2006
[Music]
the first words ever said on skype the
first words to be said on skype weren't
in English but in Estonian the mother
tongue of the country that invented the
technology in April of 2003 five words
were added by a member of the
development team the English translation
was hello can you hear me I guess it's
only fitting
he was the first Facebook user ignoring
Facebook's current controversy and calls
for Mark Zuckerberg to resign it might
be interesting to take a look at the
very first person to sign up to Facebook
so he was it the first real person on
Facebook was actually ID number for the
first three accounts were just for user
testing as he can guess ID number four
was Mark Zuckerberg himself the first
non founder to join Facebook was Ari
hoursit a university student from Israel
now with around two billion monthly
users it's fair to say that he started
something the first youtube video so I'm
sure all of you have probably seen this
before but the first video posted on
YouTube was by jared creme at the San
Diego Zoo it was uploaded on April 23rd
2005 and has been watched over 57
million times keep in mind that at the
time when they posted this video they
had no idea how big YouTube was going to
be was just a fun technical project for
them
[Music]
what was the first tweet the first tweet
was written by co-founder Jack Dorsey on
March 21st 2006 it simply read just
setting up my Twitter so what about the
first Instagram post the first photo
posted on Instagram was uploaded on July
26 2010 by Instagram CEO and co-founder
Kevin Systrom it was a photo of his dog
a golden retriever next to a taco stand
so I've traveled from 1971 to 2010 many
of the events that we've covered were
the very first steps in movements that
would change the way society interacts
and communicates so this last one is at
the top of the list not because of its
date or significance but because of its
relevance to the modern Internet
the first me it goes without saying that
traditional memes have had their day and
more often than not they fade into
obscurity pretty fast the story of the
first meme is actually pretty
interesting and the answer depends on
how you look at it the very first meme
could be recognized at the smiley face
it was first posted on the 19th of
September 1992 a Scott Fahlman during
his time at Carnegie Mellon University
he noticed that there was no way of
expressing human emotion between
text-based forum conversations between
computers because of this it was chaos
at the time jokes would be taken the
wrong way and lengthy flame wars would
ensue
Scott came up with the elegant solution
of a smiley face and it soon caught on
quickly and spread to other universities
we were being silly late at night we
were sending these things around
messages and I proposed this thing and I
thought it was just another silly
message that I sent you know I didn't
keep a copy of it and I noticed about a
week later that people were starting to
use it around Carnegie Mellon a couple
of weeks later that we got a message
back from some colleagues on the west
coast of the US and they were using it
to now and they were starting to make
these long lists you know of many
different emoticons
I only claimed responsibility for the
the colon - and the parentheses a smiley
face in the frowny face with the nose so
some of you would not be satisfied with
that definition of me so let's take a
look at the first meme that is
recognizable as a meme today this meme
is simply known as the dancing baby
it was first set loose on the 22nd of
October 1996 the dancing baby originated
as a collection of experimental testing
data files on a product sample for then
groundbreaking 3d character animation
software the software was called
character studio this baby was the first
truly viral meme as we know it today it
found its way onto hit shows of the time
like
bill and 3rd Rock from the Sun and even
the Simpsons and many of you who are old
enough will still immediately recognize
it today so there you go
so that is literally how many aspects of
the internet that you're used to seeing
and using every day started out but
there's a bit of a somber tone to the
end of this video as many of you may or
may not know the Internet as we know
will be coming to an end in early 2019
this is thanks to the European Union
originally an organization which was
meant to facilitate free trade and free
travel within Europe but slowly grew out
of control when no one seemed to notice
now the organization is so powerful that
these unelected leaders has decided to
write their own laws that will result in
the backbone of the internet hyperlinks
actually being taxed and copyright law
is so strict that all websites including
YouTube social media or any website at
all that just allows users to post will
be forced not to allow user content and
only allow content from trusted parties
to avoid liability under these new
regulations the result will most likely
be the only big companies will be
allowed to post content because they own
the rights and the website hosts can
trust them and everybody else gets left
out this proposal is known as article 13
on freedom of expression raised by
experts ranging from the UN Special
Rapporteur David Kaye to the inventor of
the World Wide Web Sir Tim berners-lee
and the real concerns voiced by our
citizens just yesterday I received a
petition signed by almost a million
people against the Judy committee
mandate huge controversy still exists
about the methods proposed something's
not right here if you want to know more
about it I'll leave some links below we
can explore more and see what you can do
to save the Internet sorry at the end on
that note but at least we can be
grateful for the internet that we have
now and hopefully we can do something
about article 13 anyway thanks for
watching this has been - go go if you
just stumbled across this channel feel
free to subscribe and
same for the next week cheers guys
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]